tenemos aquí una matriz de 4x4 y nos
encantaría sacar su determinante el
determinante de la matriz ahora hay dos
caminos para sacar este determinante
el primero es hacerlo de la forma
clásica como vimos en uno de los vídeos
que escogeremos una de las filas o una
de las columnas como quisiéramos
y vamos a escogiendo cada uno de los
elementos de esa columna o fila quitamos
la fila y la columna de la entrada y
sacábamos el determinante la sub matriz
que nos quedaba ahora utilizando ese
proceso primero tenemos cuatro
determinantes de tres por tres y después
cada uno de esos determinantes de tres
por tres se convierte en tres
determinantes de dos por dos y la verdad
es que es un relajo ya para matrices de
cuatro por cuatro son un montón de
cuentas además de que aquí no hay ceros
que hagan que nuestras operaciones sean
más sencillas
el segundo camino mucho más recomendable
y por eso vamos a verlo en este vídeo es
utilizar lo que hemos visto en estos
últimos vídeos okay seguro se acuerdan
de lo que vimos hace creo que fue hacer
dos vídeos que vimos que si teníamos una
matriz y efectuamos la operación de fila
que lo que hace es reemplazar una de las
filas por esa misma fila menos una
escalar veces otra de las filas déjame
lo escribo pero el chiste es que si
hacemos esa operación de fila el
determinante se preserva exactamente
igual que yo sea el determinante de la
matriz original de la matriz a es
exactamente igual al determinante de la
matriz a si le restamos una de las filas
a otra de las filas ok pero vamos a
escribir la muy importante eso escribir
las cosas
re
las
y la y
x
- un escalar que en este caso es una c
por
j
no cambia
al determinante de t
ok entonces si tenemos cualquier fila y
la reemplazamos por esa misma fila menos
una escalar por cualquier otra fila eso
no cambia nuestro determinante y la otra
cosa que vimos es que si teníamos una
matriz
3 triangular superior
bullard
superior comentado escribiendo verdad
bueno si tenemos una matriz triangular
superior entonces el determinante de esa
matriz es simplemente la multiplicación
de todos los términos de su diagonal
principal ok pero bueno qué es eso de
las matrices triangulares superiores
pues es simplemente una matriz que tiene
puros ceros debajo de la diagonal
principal aunque hay digamos que ésta es
una entrada esta es otra aquí tenemos
las entradas de la diagonal principal y
todas las entradas debajo de esta
diagonal son puros ceros lo que hay aquí
da un cero y aquí van dos ceros aquí
pues no sé cuántos se los vayan pero
llegamos hasta acá con ceros bueno ha
dicho en este caso que dibuje una matriz
de 5 x 5 - y otros 4 ceros pero en
general quién sabe cuántas entradas
tenemos por acá no entonces todo este
triángulo debajo de la diagonal
principal son puros ceros pero encima de
la diagonal pues no sabemos que tenemos
no sé aquí tenemos puras entradas
que quién sabe cuáles sean podrían ser 0
podrían no el chiste es que para este
tipo de matrices que tienen un triángulo
de ceros aquí hay una forma muy sencilla
de encontrar su determinante que es
simplemente tomar todos los elementos de
la diagonal principal osea estos
elementos y multiplicarlos y ese es el
determinante súper fácil en comparación
con estos determinantes que sacábamos
antes nada bueno el chiste es que
también hay una cosa similar no lo vi en
el vídeo pasado donde vimos esto de las
matrices triangulares superiores pero
que está muy relacionado y es muy
parecido y son las matrices
la matriz triangular 3
güler inferior inferior que como te
puedes imaginar es simplemente cambiar
los ceros para arriba y el resto de las
entradas para abajo que tenemos aquí una
matrix con su
y ya con el principal por aquí tenemos
quién sabe qué otras entradas que
también podrían ser 0
y por acá igual todo lleno de entradas 0
10 quién sabe pero todas las entradas
encima de la diagonal o sea todas estas
son 0
ok entonces en la matriz triangular
inferior
las entradas moradas son 0 y las
entradas lila o azuladas pueden ser 0
pueden hacerlo y las matrices triangular
superior todas las entradas naranjas
pueden ser o puede no ser 0 pero todas
las entradas verdes definitivamente son
0 no lo demostramos en el vídeo pasado
porque ni siquiera hablamos de matrices
triangulares inferiores pero de la misma
forma como probamos este resultado para
las matrices triangulares superiores el
determinante de cualquier matriz
inferior es exactamente igual a lo que
nos queda de simplemente multiplicar
todos los elementos de la diagonal
principal ok tenemos una matriz
triangular inferior y lo único que
tenemos que hacer para sacar su
determinante es multiplicar las entradas
de su diagonal principal lo cual suena
que es algo que tenemos que
aprovecharnos bueno y para aprovecharlo
lo que vamos a hacer es utilizar estas
operaciones de file que no cambian al
determinante para transformar a esta
matriz en una matriz triangular superior
y entonces lo único que vamos a tener
que hacer es multiplicar las entradas de
su diagonal para encontrar su
determinante ok entonces ese es el plan
entonces tenemos que empezar por
escribir a por acá
112 - 11 12
12 27 42 27 42 45 62 45 menos 6 12 23 12
y nada más que aquí en lugar de poner la
matriz lo que queremos es ya de una vez
sacar el determinante o sea que le vamos
a poner signo determinante si es que
aquí estamos sacando el determinante de
a
ahora usando esa operación que cambia la
fila y por la fila y menos una constante
por la fila j vamos a hacer que esta
entrada se vuelva a cero aquí entonces
vamos a dejar esta fila tal cual como
este gay y el determinante esta matriz
va a ser igual al determinante de la
matriz una vez efectuada esta operación
de fila que entonces este determinante
es igual
el determinante de aquí dejamos la
primera fila igual 12 2 1
y ahora vamos a reemplazar la segunda
fila por la segunda fila menos una vez
la primera fila ok entonces podríamos
pensar y aquí que la c es simplemente un
1 y entonces nos queda uno menos uno por
uno o sea uno menos 10 después 2 menos
20 también 4 - 2 esto es 2 y 2 - 1 eso
es un 1 ok ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo
con la tercera fila para que esta
entrada se vuelva un 0 entonces tenemos
que restarle a esta fila dos veces esta
fila gay dos menos dos por uno es un
cero aquí nuestra constante válidos y la
fila y es esta fila y la fila j es esta
fila entonces dos menos dos por 107
menos dos por dos
74 o sea 35 menos 2 por 25 menos 4 es 12
menos 2 por 1
eso es cero otra vez y finalmente este
por cierto es un signo de igual de que
está este determinante es igual a este
determinante pero finalmente vamos a
hacer que aquí haya un cero lo único que
tenemos que hacer es a esta fila sumarle
esta fila o sea que esta constante
podemos pensar que es menos 1 aunque
entonces así nos queda la cuarta fila
menos menos o sea más la primera fila
entonces menos uno más uno eso es un 0 4
+ 2
eso es un 6 menos 62 menos 4 y 3 más 14
entonces vamos a hacer lo mismo este
determinante es igual a la siguiente
matriz
lo que queremos hacer aquí es
transformar a esta matriz en una matriz
triangular superior pero aquí lo que
tenemos es que en la segunda fila hay
dos ceros entonces tal vez lo que
queremos hacer es intercambiar estas dos
filas del lugar no sea porque aquí
queremos una entrada pivote bueno en
realidad no tiene que ser pivote porque
para que sea pivote tiene que ser un 1 y
no nos importa que sea 1 3 50 o 100
simplemente con que sea algo distinto de
0 estaría bien para poder utilizar esta
fila con esta entrada distinto de 0 para
hacer que todas las de abajo de esta
entrada sean 0 que en serio sea una
matriz triangular superior entonces pues
lo que vamos a hacer es intercambiar
estas dos filas del lugar ahora la
pregunta que nos tenemos que hacer es y
hacer esa operación de filas en donde
cambiamos a esta fila con esta fila hace
que cambie el determinante y esta es una
cosa que ya vimos y si si lo cambia pero
no lo cambia de una forma tan grave o
sea simplemente si intercambiamos 2
entonces el determinante de la nueva
matriz va a ser igual a menos el
determinante original aunque hay
entonces si queremos cambiar estas dos
filas de lugar tenemos que multiplicar
este determinante por un menos para que
se siga dando esta igualdad entre estos
dos determinantes entonces vamos a
intercambiar estas dos filas de lugar y
vamos a dejar exactamente igual a estas
otras dos filas entonces tenemos por
aquí un 1 2 2 1
6 - 44 y por acá esta fila va a dar aquí
arriba entonces tenemos un 0 3 1
y esta fila de acá va a dar aquí abajo
entonces tenemos
2 y 1 ok cómo estamos poniendo aquí el
signo de menos el determinante
estas dos matrices tomando en cuenta el
signo menos son iguales
ok entonces vamos a seguir queremos que
todas las entradas de esta columna
debajo de esta entrada sean 0 así es que
queremos hacer que esta entrada se
vuelva a 0 por lo que vamos a hacer otra
de estas operaciones de chile y a la
cuarta fila le vamos a restar dos veces
la segunda fila entonces este
determinante
es exactamente igual
y dejamos las primeras dos filas
igualitas 12 21
la tercera fila también la dejamos
igualita 0 0 2 1
y finalmente tomamos esta fila menos dos
veces esta fila 0 - 2 por 0 06 menos dos
por 36 menos seis o sea 0 - 4 - 2 por
menos uno menos 6 y finalmente 4 menos
dos por cero o sea 4 entonces
necesitamos más espacio así es que
pero que no se nos olvide que este
determinante tiene que llevar su signo
de menos que tenemos aquí dos filas las
intercambiamos y entonces el
determinante esta matriz es igual a el
determinante de la matriz cambiando las
dos filas del lugar pero multiplicándose
por un signo menos entonces vamos a
tener que arrastrar hasta el final ese
signo menos para que se sigan dando
estas igualdades aunque entonces que no
se nos olvide el signo menos y vamos a
seguir aquí todavía no tenemos una
matriz triangular superior pero ya casi
ya nada más tenemos que hacer que esta
entrada se vuelva cero y aquí para que
tenemos esta otra igualdad entre
determinantes nuestro determinante
que no se nos olvide el signo de menos y
entonces pues dejamos las primeras tres
filas tal cual como están 12 21
0 2 1
la última fila la vamos a sustituir por
la última fila más tres veces la tercera
fila porque dos por tres son seis
entonces se eliminan entonces aquí 0 más
3 por 0 0 y luego 0 más 3 por 0 0 menos
seis más 3 por 2 o sea menos 660 y
finalmente cuatro más 3 por 143
y listo ya terminemos bueno está bueno
pero ya me lo terminamos porque ahora sí
esta matriz si es una matriz triangular
superior ok aquí tenemos a todo nuestro
triángulo de ceros esto es nuestra
diagonal ok
esta es la diagonal principal
y abajo de la diagonal principal tenemos
puros eros entonces es súper sencillo
calcular su determinante y ese
determinante es bueno primero que no se
nos olvide el signo menos menos
superimportante y aquí lo que tenemos
que poner es simplemente la
multiplicación de cada una de las
entradas de la diagonal principal o sea
1 por 3 por 2 por 7 y listo ese es
nuestro determinante aquí entonces pero
esto es simplemente 1 por 3 por 2 o sea
6 6 por 7 son 42 y nuestro signo de
menos y listo
este es el determinante ok entonces fue
mucho más fácil
para calcular el determinante esta
matriz utilizar estas dos propiedades de
los determinantes y con ellos
transformar al determinante de la matriz
en el determinante de una matriz
triangular superior y entonces
simplemente multiplicar los elementos de
la diagonal ok
fue muchísimo más fácil y rápido sacarlo
de esta forma que si lo hubiéramos
sacado directamente entonces nada más
hay que recordar que si intercambiamos
dos filas de lugar tenemos que
multiplicar el determinante por un signo
menos y no se nos debe de olvidar en el
camino este signo menos